i'm looking around our elected officials
these days and i got to tell you i'm a
little bit dispirited i'm a little bit
discouraged
not just with the democrats with the
republic maybe especially with the
republicans i look around at a lot of
republicans i think with republicans
like this who needs democrats it's
republicans doing the democrats jobs
for them handful of good guys out there
one of the good guys chip roy
congressman for texas's 21st
congressional district
who just spoke out pretty vigorously
against a a measure
undertaken by a lot of house republicans
that i think a lot of people don't even
know about did you know that last week
house democrats with the support of a
lot of house republicans voted to make
women sign up for the draft for the
selective service i i didn't get a whole
lot of headlines but it's pretty
shocking to me
here to help us make sense of it
chip roy chip thank you so much for
being here
michael my pleasure thanks for having me
on so
chip i'll get right to it
i
i underst i don't know a ton about how
this
bill was passed through the house i
understand it was part of a broader
defense bill and a lot of republicans
think they're getting squeezed on the
defense bill well we got to vote so we
look like we support the military but it
just seems to me
any bill that involves drafting
america's daughters is it's just
unacceptable it's just off the table
yeah i agree completely and look what
we're talking about for your listeners
is the national defense authorization
act it is true that annually on a
bipartisan basis we try to come together
to pass that bill to authorize our
national defense it is the single most
important and the primary function of
our government we all agree on that
unfortunately for a year my republican
colleagues have allowed garbage to get
attached to and voted through along with
the national defense authorization act
a lot of the reasons we have all this
woke garbage in the military now right
the
chief diversity officers the critical
race theory implication the academies
that are teaching this kind of stuff the
reason that we have a lot of things
passed
that we disagree with is because of that
we have republicans frankly who are
unwilling to challenge the defense
industrial complex unwilling to say to
the voters hey
i want to vote for a pay raise for the
troops i want to make sure they've got
what they need but i'm not going to give
them a christmas tree to pass their wish
list of leftist policies using you as
the excuse and that's exactly what they
did last week the national defense
authorization act was passed
with 25 additional billion dollars on
top of the administration asked despite
the fact that austin and millie have not
been held accountable despite the fact
there's been no actual resolution of
what they did in afghanistan and 85
billion dollars of equipment the hands
of the taliban
and they included a draft our daughter's
provision what does that mean
if this becomes law
then the law will change such that women
will have to register for selective
service as men currently do
and they will have to do so
relative immediately it'll have an
immediate effect this becomes law
now here's the problem with that
we all know you and i know any average
listener knows that's absurd it's wrong
and by the way we should have debated it
it should have been in the light of day
not passing an amendment with
135 republicans in the house two-thirds
of republicans voting for it
final point five years ago your tax
money my tax money or borrowed money
however you want to look at it spent 36
million dollars in the department of
defense to study
the effectiveness of women in combat
you will be shocked to learn
that they found
that all male units perform at a 70
proficient level relative to
mixed units and that's by the way being
conducted by your woke military i think
we all know the truth we shouldn't have
done this i oppose it there is a chance
to stop it now because it will go to the
senate the senate will mess with it and
we'll end up in a conference we should
strip it out
there are other bad provisions like red
flag laws for men and women in uniform
green garbage woken garbage but this has
to come out this drafting of our
daughters i think you're exactly right
and you point out something important
here which is the
argument from efficiency you know it's
the kind of utilitarian argument of well
the left tells us that men and women are
exactly the same people with even two
brain cells to rub together know that is
obviously not the case we know that men
physically are just bigger and stronger
and faster than women that that's just
the way it is and so it is going to uh
diminish military readiness but then
there's the other argument beyond the
utilitarian kind of calculations there's
just this question is this right or is
it wrong is it just is it good for a
country to draft our daughters
into fighting our wars for us and
getting shot by some jihadi overseas
what the hell are we even fighting for
this is so perverse it is such a sick
country and
that would do this sort of thing and it
just demonstrates such a lack of
judgment on the part of republicans who
are doing this look very little
scandalizes me anymore okay i have
fairly low expectations for for a lot of
congress and for for even some some
republicans but this is a new low even
for me and i totally agree with you this
is non-negotiable take this stupid
provision out of the law
yeah i couldn't agree more last night i
joked on tucker when we were talking
about this he was incredulous he was
like what are you talking about draft
our daughters this is insane and i said
that my wife has said that if i voted
for this she'd go out and campaign
against me because she's a rational
woman who understands why important this
how important this is now look i'm so
glad you just framed it the way you just
framed it
i make utilitarian arguments sometimes
because i want people to have the data
because they sit there and they argue
and they want to be old things are all
equal but look bottom line is what kind
of a man
would allow his government
to by force
conscript his daughter his wife his
sister his mother can you imagine
sitting at your house yeah and your wife
opens up the envelope and she goes oh my
lottery number got picked
i'm going off to war
and then you go oh don't worry trust the
government not to put your daughter into
a foxhole really trust the same
government they just left 85 billion
equipment in the hands of the taliban
trust the government that refuses to
secure our border trust the government
that is stepping into texas and saying
we can't have monoclonal antibody
treatments out of their infinite wisdom
to ration it they're stepping in and
saying oh sorry you must vaccinate every
business of employees more than 100
people through the through an
unconstitutional unlawful order by the
president of the united states trust
that government
not to draft my daughter and put her
into a foxhole i'm sorry go to hell i'm
going to protect my daughter of course
and and
you mention all of these other awful
provisions that we've gotten in in these
previous nd aaas you know these these
defense funding bills and
that includes the all the woke military
stuff that includes the chief diversity
officer it includes all the crt the
critical race theory stuff and
and i know a lot of republicans in the
past they say
oh who cares look we got to fund the
military we don't i don't want to go
back to my district and have people run
campaign ads against me that say i'm
against supporting the troops so sure
we're going to get a chief diversity
officer or some woke you know i think
millie is going to dye his hair purple
pretty soon and start you know marching
in the streets but you know that it's
not that big a deal who cares my answer
to that is
the left cares the left clearly clears
it carries they're going to hold
military funding hostage to these
provisions not because they're trivial
but because they have real significant
effects and you just think
i i agree that some of them are more
important than others but if you're not
going to take a stand on drafting our
freaking daughters then you're not going
to take a stand on anything i don't i'm
not sure that you're capable of standing
let me give you the logic of your
average member of congress okay
one i had a member of congress colleague
who the other day said well don't worry
they'll never draft their daughters and
then literally follow that up with
but if we we need to have a draft to be
able to combat china because they might
have 20 or 30 million men so then we'd
have to draft daughters i'm like wait a
minute you just said we won't ever have
a draft but then you said that we might
have to have a draft
another guy
said
well look i had to vote for the ndaa
because you know why because there's a
provision in there now that will allow
members of the military to be
dishonorably discharged i'm sorry
honorably discharged and prevent them
from being dishonorably discharged if
they choose not to be vaccinated so hold
on a second you're still going to allow
them to be forced out of the military
because they refuse to be vaccinated
maybe they've got natural immunity and
your big reason for saying we should
draft otters pass a red flag law pass a
bloated ndaa is to give them the benefit
of a honorable discharge what kind of a
freaking clown show is this congress and
why are two thirds of republicans
jumping right in bed with it i don't
understand it's just such
cowardice it's such a lack of judgment
it's it's a really it's a it's a new low
i think and so you you have given us a
little glimmer of hope though here chip
you've said that it's not as though this
is the law now it's passed out of the
house but you've still got a 50 50 50 50
senate but the democrats have the tie
breaking vote still you have a couple
sort of moderate
quasi-moderate democrats kirsten cinema
in arizona and joe manchin in west
virginia it's gonna go there's gonna be
it's gonna go into conference there
you're gonna maybe be able to strip
these things out so
one what is the likelihood they take
this this draft or daughter's provision
out and two how do we encourage our
elected representatives to do that
my experience both as a member of
congress as a staffer senator cruz's
chief of staff a lawyer and senate
judiciary is that when the people burn
the phones down these guys run to the
corners they go running crying and they
go okay whatever you say and you know
what that's good that's where system's
supposed to work right in a sense i'd
like to see better leadership
burn the bones down tell your members of
congress you don't want your daughters
sisters moms drafted that you want to
stop that we can stop it if we force
them to take it out of conference
republicans claim oh don't worry we'll
fix this in the future
fix it now don't give democrats their
show when here of an you know equity
when it's absolutely absurd kill it kill
it now we have the votes to kill the
defense authorization act we should kill
it for this reason we should kill it for
giving it more money without
accountability for milli or austin we
should kill it for the red flag law
provisions take all of that stuff out in
conference force them for some
accountability the american people need
to speak and let their members know that
they have no business supporting this
vote i think you're absolutely right and
and i do think
one i agree that congressmen and
senators don't like it when the phones
ring off the hooks and so might be a
good way to pressure them but also
conservatives have overcome greater odds
actually on this very issue people
forget about it now but you know many
decades ago the era the so-called equal
rights amendment it was gonna pass it
was guaranteed it had republican support
another bunch of squishes back then it
had a ton of democrat support and
basically just one woman stopped this
phyllis
great strong conservative woman she
organized a campaign and and she
galvanized women across the country on
this issue don't draft our daughters
don't abolish same-sex bathrooms i mean
actually a lot of the same things that
democrats are trying to do today and she
stopped that awful amendment
i agree absolutely and right now you've
got some groups concerned women for
america have scored against it the
family research council scored against
it uh on the gun side gun owners of
america scored against it we've got
other groups that are starting to poke
their head up uh i know that the
heritage foundation others have raised
concerns about this provision i hope
that there will be more noise more
groups shining a light on this and uh
for any of your listeners out there just
make sure your members of congress know
how you feel about it and again your
argument was the best one
what in the world are we thinking what
kind of a man are you if you look at
your daughter or a woman in your family
and believe the power of government
should be used to conscript her
into military service i can't imagine
anything allowing for me allowing that
to occur that's right and to look at
what's happened especially over the past
year and a half though you can look a
lot further back and to believe that if
we give this administration
this ruling class this kind of power
that they're either not going to
exercise it or they're going to give it
back to us that is a pipe dream if you
believe that brother i got a bridge in
brooklyn to sell you that is absolutely
absurd
and they want to use this for a larger
statement right they want this statement
right they want to completely break down
the barriers and say that everybody is
the same they want to say that you're a
pregnant person that's right that's
right
let's make stuff up in the face
and so
buy them this stand up stand up for
normalcy stand up for our life stand up
for your family just stop it's like our
border just secure stand up and secure
the border stop waiting for biden to do
it let's go do it as texas let's go do
it as america let's reclaim our country
it's time that's right you know a lot of
times you'll hear the squishes and the
cowards say well this is not the hill i
want to die do you want to die on this
hill i say first of all i don't intend
to die on any hill second of all if you
give up all the hills then you got
nowhere else to stand then you've given
up the entire battlefield chip uh really
i really appreciate your clarifying this
calling people's attention to it in the
house of representatives and being one
of the few guys over there that still
seems to have a spine yeah i hope you'll
live a long life and you donate your
body to science and your spine to the
gop because you've really
well michael there there are a few
others here that are standing up and
fighting we're getting more of them
every day the american people show
confidence here we can win these fights
and win more but i just don't want it to
be about republicans wanting power for
the sake of it yeah we need to do
something with it and we need to stand
up for this country banks might need to
use it for for the right stuff and for
goodness justice in the american way